إنه لشرف عظيم أن يكون هناك رئيس
أردوغان
من تركيا هنا قلة من قادة العالم
لديهم نوع العلاقة التي
رفضها رئيس تركيا مع
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والتي وصفها البعض بأنها ربما
حالت دون حدوث تمزق تام في
العلاقات التركية
التي استمرت في التدهور  بسبب
الخلافات الطويلة الأمد حول
دعم الولايات المتحدة للمقاتلين بقيادة
الأكراد في
سوريا ، تعتبر تركيا الإرهابيين
وتهديد أمنها القومي الرئيسي
لشراء تركيا العضو في الناتو
لنظام الدفاع الصاروخي الروسي s-400
الذي تسبب في فرض عقوبات أمريكية نادرة
ضد عقود من الزمن.
حليف الآن ، يرث الرئيس الأمريكي
نفس الخلافات القديمة
مع تركيا الحازمة بشكل متزايد ،
لقد تغير الكثير على مدار السنوات الأربع الماضية ،
وهذا
ليس تركيا منذ عقد مضى
مع دوره السلس في
التحالف عبر الأطلسي ، ومن
الواضح الآن أن تركيا قوة متجددة
الرغبة في أن يكون لها بصمة عسكرية
خارج حدودها
في الواقع لها وجود عسكري  في
ستة سبعة ثمانية مواقع في جميع أنحاء
الشرق الأوسط وشرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط
في ذلك ال
دخلات العسكرية لل
بيا ، وأثارت هذه السياسة الخارجية القوية غضب الكثيرين في
لمنطقة وخارج تركيا ، فهي مع
ولة إقليمياً للغاية ، لذا أعتقد أن ال
ميع يفهم أنه بحاجة إلى عل
قة جيدة مع موحد.  ينص على
علاقات أفضل لا أعتقد أنهم
يريدون البدء على أساس سيئ ،
فنحن نرى بالفعل
محوري أردوغان يحاول التحول
إلى أوروبا في هجوم ساحر
وإرسال رسائل إيجابية
إلى واشنطن منذ فوز الرئيس جو
بايدن ، كان هناك أمر واضح  تحول
في لهجة أنقرة
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسة التركية لشبكة سي إن
إن بيكي أندرسون إنهم مستعدون للتغيير
قال رئيسنا إن تركيا
مستعدة لبدء الحديث
عن شراء نظام باتريوت أو
نظام دفاعي آخر من حلفاء الناتو ، لذلك نحن
مستعدون للقيام بذلك.
التعاون
نعتقد أنه سيكون لدينا
صفحة جديدة مع إدارة بايدن
التي يعرفها تركيا
إنه يعرف المشهد السياسي التركي ،
يعرف القيادة هنا ، إنه يعرف أن
رئيسنا أتى إلى تركيا أربع مرات كنائب
للرئيس ، وأعتقد أنه سيأخذ
كل تلك الخبرة والسياق الذي تعرفه
إلى
منصبه الجديد كرئيس
للولايات المتحدة
بايدن  أشارت الإدارة الأمريكية إلى أنها
ستتخذ موقفًا أكثر تشددًا ضد
تركيا
، ومن المرجح أن تكون أقل تسامحًا بكثير مع
سجل حقوق الإنسان المتدهور الذي
تجاهله إلى حد كبير الإدارة السابقة ،
لكن البلدين ما زالا بحاجة إلى بعضهما
البعض ديك رومي بلد مهم
وأعتقد أنه من أجل  سوريا بالنسبة للعراق
ومن حيث صد
النفوذ الروسي في تركيا الشرق الأوسط
أمر مهم للغاية
، فالعلاقة التركية الروسية معقدة للغاية أيضًا ،
فهي تبدو قريبة جدًا
ولكن تركيا كذلك لكنها تحد أيضًا
من قوة بعضها البعض في مسارح
مختلفة أيضًا.  ثمين للغاية بالنسبة
لمصالحنا ، لذلك هناك كل الأسباب
التي تجعل قيادة تركيا
تعرف جيدًا هذا التعامل  مع
أمريكا بايدن
سيكون مختلفًا حقًا ،
فلن يعتمد ذلك في الغالب على علاقة شخصية
بين رئيسين
وخط هاتف مفتوح للبيت الأبيض ،
فسيكون ذلك بمثابة عودة إلى
الطرق التقليدية لممارسة الأعمال التجارية
في المؤسسة  من دولة إلى
دولة
وقد يكون ذلك مجرد إعادة ضبط هذه
العلاقة المعقدة التي تحتاجها
جومانا كراتشي سي إن إن اسطنبول